bonjour à toutes et à tous alors je
m'appelle agathe lecaron je suis
animatrice de télévision et puisqu'on
parle de télévision là où je me trouve
en ce moment même on conserve plus de 20
millions d'heures de documents radios et
télévisions on est donc au coeur de la
mémoire audiovisuelle française
alors ces images d archives vous devez
sans doute les voir passer sur votre fil
facebook par exemple sur youtube à la
télévision et je suis sûr que ça vous a
déjà fait réagir ça vous a déjà fait
sourire et je sais que vous avez devinez
où je suis je suis à bry sur marne
je suis à l'ina l'institut national de
l'audiovisuel et je vous propose à
l'occasion des journées du patrimoine de
vous emmener dans les coulisses de ce
média patrimoniale pour que vous voyez
par vous même comment en partant de
support finalement très anciens on
arrive à produire de nouvelles émissions
des vidéos pour les réseaux sociaux ou
des plateformes éducative et de
streaming
on y va
alors on va commencer la visite avec ce
qu'on appelle ici le slide le slam c'est
le service sauvegarde livraison et
archivage numérique
on va rejoindre frédéric chéreau qui va
nous expliquer comment ça marche bonjour
frédéric bonjour voila frédéric vous
êtes responsable de l'archivage
numérique à li na
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on regarde la
télévision sur nos télévisions hd sur
nos ordinateurs en france a pas toujours
été le cas
comment est ce qu'on a fait pour
conserver tous ses contenus olli n'a
depuis plus de 40 ans a cumulé un très
grand nombre de supports on est à
plusieurs millions de supports un
exemple si je prends tous les supports
et que je les mets sur la tranche
on arrive à plus de 120 km linéaires et
entreposés dans nos entrepôts à saint
pée minorée à une main 80 kilomètres
d'ici dans des conditions contrôlées à
18 degrés afin que les supports ne se
dégrade pas ah oui il ya carrément d un
cahier des charges pour pouvoir
conserver au mieux toutes les données
absolument et la 18° c pour les supports
vidéo je ne parle pas du film dans le
film par exemple il faut le conserver à
12 degrés et avec un contrôle de
l'hygrométrie très strictes donc lyn a
accumulé un grand nombre de supports et
il a fallu innover pour pouvoir
dématérialisée tous ces types de
supports dans les années 2000 li na a
entrepris de migrer tous ces anciens
supports donc on est au milieu des
années 50 vers un support qui s'appelle
la bêta numérique qui a été référence
dans l'univers professionnel ou du
visuel je me suis d'abord on est tous
ces supports ont migré sur ce type de
bande grande qu'à cette petite cassette
la bêta numérique
on en a profité à l'époque ch pour
générer une version d'exploitation de
qualité dvd et une version de visionnage
pour le début d'internet
on est début des années 2000 à partir de
2010 on a commencé à transférer toutes
ces bandes bêta numérique en fichiers le
fichier copie conforme de la qualité
qu'on avait sur cette cassette
donc on avait trois cent cinquante mille
support à l'origine on a eu trois cent
cinquante mille bande bêta numérique et
ça nous a donné 350 1000 fichiers et
aujourd'hui les techniciens sont
capables de manipuler aussi bien un
magnétoscope de la fin des années 50 que
un clavier une souris d'ordinateur
j'ai même pas que ça existe
déjà à la fin des années 50 le
magnétoscope c'est pour vous dire le de
pouce à ses chats d'accord très donc le
2 pouces vous en avez un ici très
qualitatif fin des années 50 très
qualitatif ça n'a pas été le cas dans
l'évolution de des supports ici vous
avez donc une bande de pouce 14 kg la
machine fait plus d'une tonne donc oui
on serait page vous ne la verrez pas
aujourd'hui parce qu'à travers le solde
tout simplement
ensuite pour faciliter l'exploitation on
a réduit la taille on arrive sur une
bande un pouce et ensuite on arrive à un
format un peu plus contemporain dans les
années 80 des trois-quarts de pouce les
hématies coup les bébés eu ou jeu
bobines jeu des bobines dans le même
support spir présente à la maison ce que
les vhs que l'on pouvait avoir d'accord
donc tout à été migrés sur la famille
bêta voilà qu'on retrouve dans
différents différents formats et
maintenant je me propose d'aller voir
les différents et j'ai envie de voir ces
machines qui nous permettent de voir les
contenus quand même donc on a le droit
de les voir
allons-y plastique j'ai quand même une
question frédéric est ce que tous les
contenus ont déjà été archivé
numériquement ou est ce qu'il reste
encore beaucoup de boulot alors il faut
savoir que la france est le pays plus
avancés dans cette étape de
dématérialisation du fonds patrimonial
et plus avancés du monde au monde oui
oui oui
et ici vous allez voir un certain nombre
d'équipements pour dématérialiser tous
ces anciens supports
alors juste pour avoir une idée ça
correspond à quel pourcentage de contenu
archivé numériquement plus ou moins sur
le fond patrimonial on estime qu'on est
aux environs 90 % 90 % exactement on
vous avait déjà bien travaillé
exactement voilà ces machines très
bizarre ici vous avez tous les moyens de
lecture 1 pouces trois quart de pouce
on arrive avec la famille des bêtas la
bêta numérique à ressasser la fameuse
cassette bleus de tout à l'heure des
bilans mis tout à fait donc on a usé un
grand nombre de magnéto et ensuite la
famille des cars 2 pouces alors là ça a
l'air facile et tout mais c'est soit
aussi simple à utiliser
malheureusement non les sondeurs avec le
temps et les façons de les conserver d
avoir conservé se sont dégradées et avec
le temps la colle qui fixe tout
les tous les éléments magnétique s'est
dégradée il ne reste plus que cette
fameuse cole et la bande on ne peut plus
la lire alors comment on fait on a
plusieurs étapes techniques qui vont
permettre de lui redonner de la
souplesse
ensuite on va la nettoyer avant de
pouvoir l'exploiter nous arrivons à la
clinique la fameuse la fameuse clinique
avec alexandre evans
bonjour alexandre qui vont tout faire
pour une dernière fois pouvoir lire
d'anciens support après un passage au
four après un passage à la nettoyeuse
les particules sont restés en dehors du
magnéto est là alexandre essaye de
retrouver une dernière fois des images
d'accord et du roland garros doit
conclure qu'il aurait exactement et on
va essayer d'avoir l'archivé la plus
fidèle au support d'origine
toutes les images ont été dématérialisée
maintenant on va aller dans l'espace où
tous ses fichiers numériques ces
millions de fichiers numériques sont
stockées allez on y va
bon courage merci alex
ouah
donc là c'est le saint des saints alors
ici on est au coeur de l'archivage
patrimonial à li na
c'est très impressionnant c'est rien de
le dire kedro concerne ici et sur quel
support pour tout ce qui est format
d'archivage le format le plus qualitatif
on utilise ce type de support et ce type
de machine ça s'appelle un robot et ce
robot fonctionne avec des cartouches el
teo une cartouche et théo c'est une
bande magnétique ou les la septième
génération représente 6 téra octets par
bandes
le robot peut en contenir dix mille ça
nous fait une capacité de 60 pétaoctets
60 pétaoctets ses soixante mille
ordinateurs que vous avez à la maison
soixante mille ordinateurs bien entendu
pour t'apprendre la place mais un peu
moins quand même que 60000 ordinateur un
petit peu au moins mon rôle ici c'est
d'essayer de densifier au maximum
l'information
alors finalement ça représente combien
d'heures de contenu plus ou moins cette
salle là alors la base de données
représente plusieurs millions d'eur
serviront ces 100 millions c'est
on y arrivera un jour non aujourd'hui
d'un point de vue fonds patrimonial on
est un peu plus de 2 millions d'heures
oui s'il fallait commencer à regarder 24
heures sur 24 des programmes faudrait à
peu près 120 ans ça prend un petit peu
de vie quoi
et en volume 2 en nombre de fichiers on
est à peu près à 17 millions fichiers
quoi et sur votre téléphone vous arrivez
à bien gérer vos 1000 photos que vous
avez dessus non
donc c'est forcément quelque chose de
compliqué ici il faut savoir gérer 17
millions de fichiers et imaginez le
temps qu'il faut pour migrer toutes ces
données vers un nouveau système il faut
savoir que toutes les images d archives
que vous allez que vous pouvez voir sur
internet ou à la télé il ya 99% de
chances que ça parte dit d'accord de
cette machine de celui-ci ou de son
clown dans l'autre datacenter que ce
soit donc 1950 ou 2019 ou 2019
le trafic c'est une enfant car je me
nourris de la famille musicale d'airé
sur l'adour en direct de alors pour
mieux comprendre comment toutes ces
pépites se retrouvent sur votre
téléphone je vais vous emmener dans un
endroit qu'on appelle le plateau en fait
c'est le coeur de la rédaction de l'ina
et je vais vous présenter une
responsable éditorial de l'ina qui
s'appelle elodie le lieu était juste là
au jour elodie bonjour un gain merci
d'être là parce que j'ai plein de
questions à vous poser là en fait on
vient de voir comment on numériser tous
les contenus à l'ena et j'aimerais
savoir ce qu'on en fait après c'est la
bonne nous on part de l'art chiffres
bruts mais on va transformer ça en vidéo
à destination de tout le monde
en vérité l'idée c'est vraiment de
s'appuyer sur des documentalistes qui
vont aller dénicher le but contenu qu'on
va pouvoir mettre en regard de
l'actualité très important qu'on va
pouvoir éditorialisé et ensuite qu'on va
pouvoir mettre à disposition sur tout un
tas de plateforme facebook youtube
instagram twitter le site de l'ina en
gros l'année dernière au 2019 ont fait
720 millions de vidéos vues et cette
année en 2020 on a déjà dépassé ce
chiffre
ça c'est le plateau avec pas mal de
journalistes et rédacteurs qui met tous
les jours des vidéos en ligne mais est
ce qu'on peut dire elodie que lina
aujourd'hui c'est un média à part
entière
on peut tout à fait dire ça en effet
l'idée c'est vraiment de trouver du sens
né du contexte en fait à toutes ses
archives et notamment de rebondir à
l'actualité en offrant des clés de
compréhension au plus grand nombre
donc c'est aller chercher vraiment une
archive qui va résonner avec l'actualité
qui va permettre d'éclairer vraiment une
actualité forte humoristique grave mais
avec quelque chose de nostalgique on
joue sur ces codes là sans en abuser
or vous déployez vos offres sur un
réseau très très large mais est-ce que
vous avez aussi des offres grand public
des offres éducatives a proposé tout à
fait en fait on a lancé tout récemment
lu milka une offre je connais des ragots
gic tu connais bien l'idée c'est
vraiment d'avoir une offre à destination
des enseignants des publics scolaires et
d'avoir vraiment des outils pédagogiques
on a également déployé culture prime il
ya quelques années avec nos amis de
l'audiovisuel public donc une offre
vraiment culture société réseaux sociaux
complètement et on a récemment sorti
madeleine qui est notre offre de
streaming illimité sur abonnement
premiers mois offert de 0,99 et qui
permet d'accéder à tout un tas de
programmes séries fictions documentaires
quoi par exemple ma recommandation pour
cette semaine c'est notamment isabelle
huppert qui est à la fiche de darron et
on à isabelle huppert dans ses premières
télés avec madeleine dans les années 70
matip et on a tout un tas de téléfilms
super donc on tape isabelle huppert et
tout à coup on a un spectre d'image
d'elle depuis les années 70 voilà on a
plein de programmes avec isabelle
huppert on a plein programme on a duré
de charles
on a des concerts on a plein de choses
c'est une offre qui est super sympa
merci beaucoup elodie vous m'avez parlé
tout à l'heure de documentaliste j'ai
bien envie d'en savoir un tout petit peu
plus
[Musique]
dessus avec mathilde bureau qui est
responsable documentaire bonjour matilda
bonjour comment vous faites matile pour
trouver le bon document au milieu deux
millions d'heures d'archivés j aimerais
bien avoir votre secret parce que ça me
paraît impossible on a priori quels
secrets
les documentalistes de l'ina cherche
dans les fonds qui sont décrits qui
décrivent les images et les sons et
aussi parce qu'ils ont des connaissances
une très bonne connaissance des faux le
fonds de l'ina est un fonds vaste et
très riche et depuis des années il ya un
des plans de valorisation de ces fonds
qui ont été menées et qui permettent à
travers par exemple des dossiers
thématiques de retrouver encore à
l'heure actuelle des trésors et ils
exemple oui des choses qu'on n'aurait
pas imaginé pouvoir trouver il ya
quelques années exactement alors
maintenant et que le développement des
plateformes de l'ina et comment est ce
que votre métier a évolué avec l'arrivée
des plateformes et l'essor des réseaux
sociaux
la valorisation des contenus a
complètement pris son envol et du coup
le métier de documentaliste s'est adapté
à la stratégie éditoriale de l'ina donc
l'objectif maintenant c'est de proposer
des contenus pertinents
sélectif pour répondre à un fait
d'actualité pour éclairer le présent
avec le passé où pour partager un moment
du patrimoine audiovisuel avec
l'ensemble des le plus de monde possible
vous avez un exemple de pépites que
qu'on aurait retrouvé et oui il y en a
encore nous avons il ya peu retrouvé la
première les premières images filmées de
miles davis en 1957
c'était à l'occasion d'une émission
qu'il allait enregistrer aux buttes
chaumont pour une émission de variétés
qui s'appelait au clair de lune qui
était réalisé par jean-christophe averty
un grand monsieur de la télévision et
cette séquence
depuis 62 ans était réputé introuvable
et au cours d'un inventaire dans un
centre de conservation à l'ina on a en y
retomber sur ses bobines qui était mal
indiqués et ça a été une énorme surprise
beaucoup d'émotion si dans pour beaucoup
de monde
merci beaucoup mathy vous en prie
[Musique]
bonjour vincent je vous embête pas vous
êtes chargé de création digitale ici à
l'ina on vient de voir comment les
documentalistes arriver à trouver les
bonnes images
une fois que vous vous lavez cette image
qu'est ce que vous en faites quel est
votre métier mon métier ça va être de
valoriser en fait ces archives en les
remontant et en les réhabilitant à
travers une charte graphique et une
charte éditoriale
voilà pour essayer de de pouvoir les
mettre sur les réseaux qu'elle soit dans
le bon format pour les réseaux c'est ça
voilà qu'elle soit réseaux sociaux
compatibles il ya un gros cahier des
charges pour qu'elle soit réseaux
sociaux compatible wii un cahier des
charges on travaille avec des community
managers qui respectent une charte
éditoriale qui suit l'actualité la
majorité du temps et une charte
graphique aussi qu'on applique sur les
réseaux sociaux facebook et instagram
alors là vous êtes en train de
travailler sur quoi par exemple alors là
par exemple je mélange deux archives
c'est à dire que je travaille sur une
archives sonores issues issus de la
radio de la radio voilà de france
culture où on a un témoignage d'un
écrivain qui nous parle des du premier
métro parisien et en même temps voilà
pour illustrer ses propos et ben on va
se servir des images d'archivés du
premier métro parisien on voit par
exemple ici on voit ici par exemple et
prom les premiers paraît enfin les
parisiens profitant du métro man
et alors ça ça va aller ensuite sur une
plate forme voilà sur facebook et
installeur ok bon ben je vous en faites
pas plus longtemps merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
le docteur henri ghéon qui était un
écrivain de la première nouvelle revue
française
il lui arrivait de passer des journées
entières dans le métro parmi les
plateformes qui ont beaucoup de succès à
l'ina évidemment youtube 2 millions et
mais d'abonnés plus de 40 chaînes
seb vous êtes responsable de youtube à
li na
comment est ce qu'on fait émerger la
bonne archives au bon moment il ya
plusieurs choses
il ya déjà tout savoir il ya déjà un
travail d équipe parce que c'est une
vraie équipe
youtube on travaille beaucoup et les
documentalistes on réfléchit en fait à
ce qui pourrait intéresser les gens en
réaction à l'actualité ou de la pépite
qui peut ressortir en actualité on a par
exemple le pangolin active avec l'aco
vide et on s'est dit mais qui pourrait
avoir parlé du pangolin de façon un peu
décalé et on a trouvé pierre desproges
café d'un signal une chronique dessus
notre chose qui peut intéresser les gens
c'est le regard sur la société d'avant
auprès des jeunes on s'adresse à un
jeune public sur youtube youtube c'est
une plate forme qu'à un public est
relativement jeune et on leur montre
comment était la société avant dix ans
est-ce que c'est mieux avant par
l'interrogation est ce qu'il y ait des
nouvelles chaînes à venir oui il y aura
beaucoup de nouvelles chaînes à venir
dont une qui va démarrer très
prochainement qui est une chaîne qui est
fait avec thierry ardisson et qui va
s'appeler in à artix tube c'est un scoop
que vous me donnez là ou pas un peu je
suis trop fier des mois d'après quoi du
lexomil du tranxène du valium xanax je
peux dire la vérité
oui j'ai pris un quart l'exo un quart
voilà voilà
parce que je suis terrorisée voilà je
suis meilleur à l'écrit qu'à l'oral je
crois dans ton métier c'est mieux on
après je suis là bon eh bien j'espère
que cette visite vous aura plus que vous
en savez un tout petit peu plus surtout
ces images que vous voyez sur les
réseaux sociaux sont les plateformes que
vous en savez un petit peu plus sur
cette institution kelly n'a donc moi je
vous dis à très bientôt